maybe it was Ann Coulter said we need to  repeal the 19th Amendment and she's I'm  sure she said it more than one time sure  but I was talking to Elise about this  and Elisa this was early on in our sweet  little lease and my dating life and she  goes oh my gosh that's that's crazy you  know what come on and I sort of thought  I said well  what's the point of voting  because what what you were being asked  right now you sweet little Alicia would  you give up your vote to have a better  political outcome so I thought of it and  I said because women vote for Democrats  and Men vote for Republicans it's more  complicated than that but basically but  basically that's right right and  I thought well young people vote for  Democrats and older people vote for  Republicans so if you told me tomorrow  Michael the only people over 50 get to  vote right would I agree to that I  absolutely would agree to that I'd lose  my vote right right but I'd have a  better political outcome for my  community